okay
all right our uh
next witness is dr carl sagan of cornell
university a man who
needs no introduction he comes to us
today from the
center for radio physics and space
sciences we welcome you and
we're very pleased that you would take
the time out of your
schedule to come to a place like
washington where everything seems to be
living in today and not in
tomorrow to share with us your
particular view of how our past and our
present
may well affect our future carl thank
you very much
thanks very much senator dernberger
senator gore senator burdick
i'm
glad to be here
uh as i understand my uh
my function it is uh to
give some sense of what the greenhouse
effect is
to try to say something about uh
greenhouse effect on uh on other planets
uh
to uh again underscore that this is uh
is a real phenomenon
and then uh
perhaps i can take liberty to say a few
remarks about
what to do about it
the
power of
human beings to
affect and
control and change the environment is
growing as our technology grows
and at present time we clearly have
reached the stage where we are
capable
both
intentionally and inadvertently
to make significant changes in the
global climate and in the global
ecosystem and we've probably been doing
on a smaller scale things like that
for a very long period of time
for example slash and burn agriculture
which has been with us for tens of
thousands of years probably
changes the climate to some extent
by changing the albedo the reflectivity
of the earth
that massive changes have occurred is
clear from the historical record for
example egypt was once the bread basket
of the roman empire
it may be the same
role as the american midwest plays today
that is certainly no longer the case is
not a greenhouse effect
issue it
may be an overgrazing issue but is an
example of how humans are perfectly
capable of making
these unexpected and inadvertent changes
because the effects occupy more than a
human generation
there is a
tendency to say that they are not our
problem
of course then they are nobody's problem
not on my tour of duty not on my term of
office it's something for the next
century let the next century worry about
it but the problem is
that
there are effects and the greenhouse
effect is one of them which have long
time constants if you don't worry about
it now it's too late later on
and so in this issue as in so many other
issues
we are passing on extremely grave
problems for our children
when the time to solve the problems if
they can be solved at all
is now
if you um
if you ask what determines the earth's
climate clearly the main the main thing
that determines it is sunlight sunlight
is what heats the earth
not all the light that
arrives at the earth from the sun goes
to eating the earth some of it is
reflected back it's just the
the part that is absorbed
and what happens is there's a certain
rate at which sunlight is absorbed by
the earth's surface and there's a
certain rate at which the earth's
surface
radiates to space what comes from the
sun is in the ordinary visible part of
the spectrum that arises sensitive to
what the earth radiates into space is in
the infrared part of the spectrum longer
waves than red that our eyes are not
sensitive to but it's as legitimate
excuse me a form of light as the kind
that we're
that we're uh used to
now if you calculate what the
temperature of the earth ought to be
from how much sunlight is being absorbed
uh equalling how much infrared radiation
would be radiated to space
you find that the earth's temperature
by this simple calculation is too low
it's about 30 centigrade degrees too low
and
why is it too low it's too low because
something was left out of the
calculation what was left out of the
calculation the greenhouse effect
the air between us is transparent
except in los angeles in places of that
sort uh in the ordinary visible part of
the spectrum we can see each other
but if our eyes were sensitive at say 15
microns in the infrared we could not see
each other the air would be black
between us and that's because
in this case carbon dioxide carbon
dioxide is very strongly absorbing
at 15 microns and other wavelengths in
the infrared
likewise there are parts of the infrared
spectrum where water vapor absorbs where
we could not see each other if
if we were only as far apart as we are
in this room
if you add these infrared absorbing
gases to a planetary
to a planet then what happens is
the sunlight comes in as before but when
the surface tries to radiate the space
in the infrared
it is blocked it is impeded by the
absorbing gases and so the surface
temperature has to rise
so that there is an equilibrium between
what comes in and what goes out so this
is the greenhouse effect it is a
misnomer for more reasons than one it's
a misnomer in particular because that's
not how the florist greenhouse works but
that's a very minor point
there are other gases which absorb in
the
infrared uh all of the many of which
have been mentioned already nitrous
oxide methane the halocarbons and these
are products partly of
agriculture it's
fertilizers refrigeration
aerosol spray cans and so on all
products of our technology
we don't generate much water into the
atmosphere but we certainly do generate
a great deal of carbon dioxide through
the burning of wood and
fossil fuels and apparently benign
[Music]
activity who could object to humans
burning
oil and
coal gas and wood
i'd like to stress that the greenhouse
effect makes
life on earth possible if there were not
a greenhouse effect the temperature
would as i say be
30 centigrade degrees or so colder and
that's well below the freezing point of
water everywhere on the planet
the oceans would be solid after a while
a little greenhouse effect is a good
thing
but there is a delicate balance of these
invisible gases
and
too much or too little greenhouse effect
can mean too high or too low
a temperature and here we are pouring
enormous quantities of co2 and these
other gases into the atmosphere every
year with hardly any concern about its
long-term and global consequences
now
certainly not all aspects of
how
increased
co2 and other gases into the atmosphere
affect the climate are known there are
still many uncertainties although the
overall picture is i think quite clear
and uh quite widely understood and
accepted but there are questions about
aerosols about clouds you heat up the
earth how much increase or decrease in
cloudiness is there how does that change
the albedo or reflectivity of the earth
there's questions about the
ocean
and
its response time to an increase in co2
there are feedback effects
and
therefore it is certainly worthwhile to
spend some additional money on further
research on the subject
uh another point is that um
the significant temperature changes on
the earth between uh
ice ages and out of ice ages glacial and
interglacial time periods seems to be
connected with quite small changes in
the amount of sunlight that reaches the
earth due to changes in
the earth's orbital properties and that
is a
suggestion
that
the earth's climate system may be uh
very delicately dependent on the sorts
of factors
that we're talking about here and that's
why it makes sense to study past
climatic change
on the earth as an attempt to
obtain some
calibration
another source of calibration is uh the
other planets
uh every planet with an atmosphere has
some degree of a greenhouse effect the
most spectacular case by far
is the greenhouse effect of venus it's
the nearest planet it's a planet about
the same mass radius density
as the earth but
it uh is spectacularly different in
several respects one of which is that
the surface temperature is about 470
degrees centigrade 900 fahrenheit and
that
enormous temperature
um
is not due to its being closer to the
sun because venus is surrounded with
bright clouds and in fact
because it reflects so much light back
to space if that's all that was
happening it would be cooler not warmer
than the earth
the reason for this uh
absurdly high temperature on the surface
of venus which is uh well understood i
mean soviet spacecraft have landed on
venus and in effect stuck out a
thermometer there's no doubt that the
surface temperature is very high
and and later u.s spacecraft have as
well
the reason is a massive greenhouse
effect in which carbon dioxide plays the
major role
now the amount of co2 in the venous
atmosphere is much larger than here
the atmosphere is almost entirely carbon
dioxide and there's 90 times more of it
there than here
but it is an indication of
what
can
happen in an extreme case you look at
mars or jupiter or titan the big moon of
saturn and you have additional examples
of greenhouse effects different gases
different amounts of sunlight reaching
the surface different planetary albedos
and cloudiness
and in all those cases there is also a
greenhouse effect
in addition
it has been possible to calculate those
greenhouse effects
fairly accurately so that the kind of
theoretical
armamentarium
which is used to calculate the
greenhouse effect greenhouse effect
changes on the earth is also used for
other planets and therefore can be
calibrated to some extent against those
other planets if we keep coming out with
the right answer in all those different
cases then probably we understand fairly
well how greenhouse effects work
it would however
be worthwhile
in along the lines that
senator gore was talking about
to uh have an increased program through
nasa to understand the greenhouse
effects on other planets this might be a
very uh practical
uh
application
of planetary exploration
as you've heard the uh the best
estimates they certainly have some
uncertainty attached to them
are that uh at the present rate of
burning of fossil fuels the present rate
of increase of minor infrared absorbing
gases in the earth's atmosphere that
there will be a several centigrade
degree temperature increase
uh on the earth global average uh by the
middle uh to the end
of the next century and that has a
variety of consequences including uh
redistribution of local climates and uh
through the
melting of
glaciers an increase in global sea level
there is concern
on a somewhat longer time scale about
the collapse of the west antarctic ice
sheet
and a general rise of
many many meters
in
in sea level
so uh
we we have a kind of handwriting on the
wall
uh certainly there's more research to be
done but as i say there is a consensus
what can be done about it
the idea that we should
immediately stop burning fossil fuel
has such severe economic consequences
that no one of course will take it
seriously but there are
many other things that can be done
one has to do with
subsidies for fossil fuels more
efficient use
could be
encouraged by
fewer government subsidies
secondly there are alternative energy
sources
some of which are
useful
at least locally
solar power is
certainly one that might be of more
general use
safe fission power plants which are in
principle possible
and then on a longer time scale
the prospect of fusion
power fission infusion power plants in
principle
vent no infrared active gases and
therefore
whatever other problems they may
provide they do not provide a greenhouse
problem
i'd like to close by just saying a few
words on the uh
the kind of perspective that this
problem as related problems posed to us
here is a problem
which transcends
our particular generation it is an
intergenerational problem
if we don't do the right thing now
there
are very serious problems that our
children and grandchildren will have to
face
it is also a global problem it is no
good if uh just one or two major
industrial nations take
major steps to prevent
a
major increase still further in co2 and
other greenhouse gases because other
nations may uh
through
their industrial development
caused the problem by themselves and not
to say that this is inevitable but just
to give an example
uh the largest coal reserves on the
planet are the united states soviet
union and china china is undergoing a
very major
industrial development
and the burning of coal is certainly uh
something that must be very attractive
uh for the chinese looking into uh the
future
uh
i would say that there is no way to
solve this problem even if the united
states and the soviet union uh were to
come to a perfectly good accord on this
issue without involving china and many
other nations that will be
developing rapidly
in the time period we're talking about
so
here is a um
a
sense in which the nations to deal with
this problem
uh have to uh
make a change from their traditional
concern about themselves and not about
the planet and the species a change from
the traditional short-term objectives to
longer-term objectives
and we have to bear in mind that in
problems like this
the initial stages of
global temperature increase one region
of the planet might benefit while
another region of the planet uh suffers
and there has to be a kind of uh trading
off
of
of benefits and uh
and suffering and that requires a degree
of international amity which uh
certainly doesn't uh exist today
i think that what is essential for this
problem is a global consciousness a view
that transcends our exclusive
identifications with the generational
and political groupings into which by
accident we have been born
the solution to these problems requires
a perspective that embraces the planet
and the future because we are all in
this greenhouse together thank you mr
chairman well thank you very much just a
frustration on international amity
some of us made a brief
trip in august through
[Music]
sweden switzerland
germany and then i went into poland
concerned about what we call acid rain
and
some of those consequences and
as i went
the urge in me for some
forum
for international amity just it kept
crying out particularly when i got to
poland which is the
home place of
my mother's side of my family and
to
see the self-destructiveness of that
economy
and
on the people of that country
and the lack of amity on the part of the
czechs
on the part of the
east germans
it's just a frustrating experience you
must all of you must experience it every
day of your lives and
um
i i hope there is an answer in something
other than legislation
but it is your concerns and those many
of us
people who are
familiar with some parts of this this
problem and related problems uh
i guess have to take somehow take this
place beyond
an amendment to require the united
states contribution to the united
nations to be no greater
than the contribution of the soviet
union
and to somehow
lift
the people that
claim a right to a place in the united
states senate beyond that kind of a view
of the world and
and uh lifted up somewhere closer to the
the real issues that affect people and i
just why i had to say that i was
listening to
to your comments um
let me ask you and i'm intend to ask the
other witnesses
[Applause]
this and that is whether the following
is an accurate summary of the current
state of our knowledge on this subject
now for the first time there is
international scientific consensus that
global warming can and will occur
while there's still uncertainty
surrounding these predictions it runs in
both directions that is while global
warming could be less than expected it
is at least as likely that it will be
much worse
third all predictions are based on the
assumption that a new man-made
atmosphere will behave in the same way
that natural atmospheres have in the
past
fourth global warming much like fever in
a human being
is serious in it itself but is also a
symptom of massive perturbation of the
natural physical and chemical processes
and fifth
relatively painless actions can be taken
which would slow the warming trend for
example the use of cfcs and spray cans
could be banned
throughout the world
maybe cars and trucks could be required
to meet stringent carbon monoxide
standards such as those in the united
states again maybe depending on our
international amity
and forests can be
reseeded
is that a
fairly accurate summary of the current
state of
our knowledge i uh the only uh statement
in
there that uh i would have some quibble
with is the one which goes uh
that
scientists are assuming
that the the atmosphere with the new
with the increased uh
infrared absorbing gases in it will act
the same as the present atmosphere uh i
don't believe there's any such
assumption there are calculations from
first principles but apart from that
what you read seems seems
you were
invited to testify because you're
something of a
scientific generalist and one of your
best qualities is the ability to explain
complex scientific issues in a way the
layman can understand and you have also
worked on a variety of these issues
one scientist who works in this field
was recently asked why he was devoting
so much time and attention to it when
there seemed to be more urgent
problems in his response was that in his
judgment climate alteration was the most
serious threat to humanity and global
peace short of nuclear war
those seem like
strong words even from a person who's
committed
his entire life to the problem
you are more of a generalist than the
person i'm quoting and you have spent
time considering the implications of
other threats including nuclear winter
in the context of potentially
cataclysmic events
how would you score climate alteration
it's
i recognize the need for a rank order of
catastrophes so we
we know which one to devote our
attention to first
but uh i would hope that we could
concentrate on several potential
catastrophes at the same time which two
or
three i
certainly agree with your
anonymous informant that
nuclear war is
far and away heads and shoulders
the most
dangerous threat to the nation and the
world and
possibly the human species
uh i also agree that uh
the
sorts of
climatic effects that
we're talking about today
are very serious
because they have global
purview
and
because they're so intimately tied to
something which we are so reluctant to
give up for clear economic and other
reasons namely the burning of
fossil fuels
in 1945 after
the first nuclear explosions einstein
said
that everything had changed except our
way of thinking
a remark that certainly is still
applicable today
and i think is applicable to this
particular
issue
and that's what i was trying to uh to
stress in my testimony that there is a
kind of
global
and intergenerational thinking
that is essential for dealing with these
problems the nuclear war issue as well
and
other candidate catastrophes like aids
and other new epidemic diseases
all of which cannot be resolved except
on a
on an international global basis the
eradication of smallpox for example to
take a successful example
was done at the expenditure of
a few tens of millions of dollars by a
planetary
effort
by the medical community
and is an example on of a problem that
certainly was considered very difficult
uh some uh a thousand years ago uh that
is now uh
it's completely gone there are no more
cases of smallpox on the planet so it's
a reminder to us that these problems can
be solved but
not
if we persist in
keeping to our
narrow
frames of interest in space and in time
thank you thank you
dr sagan uh
a lot of has been written about a lot of
people spoken about some of the adverse
effects of increased carbon dioxide and
other gases
are there any benefits
that is uh one can argue that some of
the colder climates of our country you
know
warmer temperatures would help
well
having just come from upstate new york i
know what you mean senator marcus
uh
the
the distinguished scientists who will
follow me on this panel uh
would be better qualified than i to
answer that question but
uh
it is clear that increased carbon
dioxide
for many plant species produces a more
luxuriant growth that's true both of
crops and of weeds but
that might be considered a benefit also
the one that you just talked about there
are places that are cold which will be
happy to be warmer there are places that
have a moderate climate that will be on
unhappy about being warmer and that's
that balancing out
of
pluses and minuses i was talking about
before but i don't think anybody will be
happy about the inundation of all the
coastal cities on the planet
except i suppose the uh
the uh people who live on the new on the
new coastlines who will be delighted to
have
yeah
are there
is there any
difference of opinion at all within the
scientific community
over this trend
that is you know with increased carbon
dioxide and other gases building up
that um by sometime next century it's in
year 2075 year 2080
again the overall temperature will have
increased x number of degrees fahrenheit
defer to
doctors
others
on this but
if you look at the 1982 national academy
report
i've got the exact title but uh climatic
effects of co2 a reassessment something
like that
uh they talk about a few
dissenting
uh scientific papers
and indeed that is a few scientists who
say the effect is not nearly as severe
as has been widely advertised
and the academy's report
gives a
very
succinct
explanation about why these studies are
inadequate so your judgment the vast
preponderance of the
thinking of the community is the is in
accordance with what you're saying yes
okay
what what's the best international
arena
within which to address some of these
problems i mean we have to create
a new
forum
organization should we work within
some existing
uh organizations do we deal with this an
ad hoc basis uh what
guidance can you give us at least in
your thinking as to how to
get other countries
a think about this
including this country
b how to
work in some cooperative constructive
bases well it seems to me that
that
the situation has to be arranged
that everyone benefits
and
[Music]
a developing country that is being asked
to forego readily available
supplies of fossil fuels
uh has to be given something of value in
exchange
and uh if we develop fusion power plants
that are effective for example then it
seems to me there has to be a i wonder
if you'd give me thoughts to process in
addition to the information
substance i think
i'm going to have to break and get over
to vote and
i want to express my appreciation to you
thank you so much being here today on
behalf of all of us and for those who
aren't here
okay
um
i've got to leave too
okay well i didn't have a good answer
anyway
well you have about 50 minutes to think
about
recess the hearing thank you very much
for coming did you want to do you want
to
ask more questions oh well i have more
questions so we can if he's busy i could
talk directly
i'll write questions
[Music]
foreign